there's almost these two different
narratives that we have about our 20s
one narrative is
it's it's your 20s it's for exploration
like you know it's all good and the
other narrative is actually your 20 is
this for building up some kind of
structure and for getting ahead in your
career and for starting to grow your
income Because by the time you're in
your 30s and you settle down and start
having kids you'll be really glad that
you actually grinded in your 20s which
unlocks more freedom and more autonomy
and more like ability to spend time with
your kids whereas if you screwed around
in your 20s now you're 30 and working in
an entry-level job and getting home at
8pm and unable to spend time with your
kids because you haven't enough money
kind of stuff yeah and both of those
seem fairly compelling to me like I know
it's hard right how do you how do you
think about this so I think that you can
have both and I know it's really hard to
say that but you know I I had a nine to
five job up until very recently and
I I think that we have this very because
I get both right because I get the idea
of being like I want to ensure my future
is one that is secure and all of those
things but then I also want to have fun
and it's such a self-limiting belief to
think that it's an either it's it's kind
of black and white right like either you
choose this path or you choose the other
there are so many moments in the day
that are yours to create and yours to
make good and for you to create memories
in those and you can pursue Financial
Security you can pursue the beginnings
of a very fruitful career while still
allowing yourself time to take risks
still allowing yourself time to go and
explore and to travel and I think it's
all about this balance and also
consistency so I'm going to give a
personal anecdote here because I really
could only speak to my experience but I
finished uni I went straight into
consulting which I feel like a lot of
people do right Consulting was this very
broad stroke career idea it was very
structured I was like I can do this
and for a while there I was like all
right this is the path that we've chosen
I'm gonna start saving money I want a
house by the time I'm 27 so that I can
set up for my future and I did that for
a while but at the same time I was doing
my podcast right on the side and I was
using some of those extra hours that we
get in a day to feed into my creativity
and to take a bit of a risks and do
something that I enjoyed and slowly but
surely that actually begun to overtake
the nine to five so it's about achieving
balance by allowing yourself time to
pursue the other things if you've
decided that your nine to five or your
career as your main focus
um where does where does your life fit
in with that when I say life I mean like
the important things about life I mean
where do your friends sit in what are
your memories sitting what is your
family sit in what is love sit in where
does all those beautiful joyful things
fit into that equation or if you're
someone who is like I'm gonna go and
travel I'm going to go and experience
the world I think it's you got to
understand that at some point there will
be some responsibilities that are going
to come up that might jeopardize that
you don't need to think about them now
but just have like a vague idea of what
that is and maybe do some things in that
time around your traveling to set up for
the future like go and get a diploma or
get some make a tangible investment in
your future self so maybe that's setting
up
um some kind of
I don't know I don't do investing so I'm
not going to give Financial advice but
maybe like set up a portfolio or
something like that
um or invest in your education or invest
in some kind of unique skill that you
can bring to the table that when you
decide maybe it's time to settle down
you have that to fall back on right I
think it's this balance you don't have
to you don't have to choose one or the
other and that's it for the rest of your
life hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye